that incident happened last wednesday  just before noon the call came in from  the range 702 in the area of dean martin  and sunset  police say the suspect now identified as  marvin payton had tried to steal a gun  from a customer's bag  and became aggressive with employees  when confronted  when officers arrived at the scene  payton was outside the building he  refused to listen to the officer's  commands  and became aggressive attacking one of  the officers with a screwdriver  that led to shots fired as the injured  officer fell to the ground  officer wynn and three employees of the  business discharged their firearms  striking mr payton  officers immediately summoned medical  personnel but mr payton succumbed to his  injuries at the scene  now the officer who was injured was  treated and released from the hospital